[Música]
hoy vamos a intentar responder a una
pregunta que yo creo que puede ser
sencilla
tenemos una diapositiva aquí
aquí está
de verdad en el siglo 21 es necesario
quemar algo para obtener energía y
cuando digo quemar me refiero a [ __ ]
algo una sustancia que tiene carbono y
prenderle fuego
y la verdad es que hasta el siglo 16 el
hombre no tuvo que utilizar ningún tipo
de combustible fósil para proveerse de
energía
teníamos el viento para mover los barcos
o los molinos teníamos los animales para
realizar los trabajos pesados y tenemos
el fuego producido con leña para
calentarnos para las fraguas para
cocinar pero en el siglo 16 algo pasó en
londres una crisis energética
londres la población había crecido mucho
y era muy difícil conseguir leña para
toda la población
y apareció junto a la palabra crisis
como siempre la palabra oportunidad le
apareció un nuevo combustible el carbón
con mayor densidad y el uso del carbón
nos trajo la oportunidad de la
revolución industrial su uso en las
máquinas de vapor permitió un desarrollo
tecnológico que llega hasta el día de
hoy
desde entonces hemos utilizado
primero carbón luego petróleo luego gas
toda una economía basada en un sistema
energético basado a su vez en
combustibles fósiles
y hemos llegado hasta aquí con un 80 por
ciento de dependencia de esos
combustibles fósiles un poquito
relevante pero solamente un poquito
basado en electricidad
pero yo creo que este modelo energético
que viene desde el siglo desde la
revolución industrial está también en
crisis y está en crisis porque no es
sostenible y yo digo que no es
sostenible por tres causas la primera
muy importante es la competitividad un
sistema energético para ser sostenible
tiene que ser competitivo si bien es
cierto que los combustibles fósiles
cuando son abundantes son muy
competitivos también es cierto que
tenemos en la memoria reciente épocas en
las cuales ha habido escasez y cuando
haya escasez el precio ha sido muy
volátil y el precio ha sido elevado
dando lugar a graves crisis económicas
el segundo aspecto es la seguridad de
suministro seguridad y calidad en el
suministro y también hemos vivido
momentos tensos con los combustibles
fósiles con crisis del petróleo que
todos podemos recordar en el siglo
pasado el tercer elemento y muy
importante tiene que ver con el impacto
ambiental un sistema energético tiene
que ser cuidadoso con el medio ambiente
los combustibles fósiles han provocado
problemas por ejemplo relacionados con
la lluvia ácida pero realmente ahora el
mundo se encuentra en una crisis
ambiental en una crisis climática
provocada en gran parte por las
emisiones de co2 que estos combustibles
fósiles expulsan a la atmósfera
de nuevo la palabra crisis tiene que
venir acompañado de la palabra
oportunidad pero tenemos de verdad
recursos energéticos suficientes que
sean sostenibles para alimentar al
planeta yo creo que la respuesta a esta
pregunta es sí
dispongamos de esta manera
cada hora llega a la tierra suficiente
energía solar para alimentar el planeta
durante un año o de esta otra manera si
utilizáramos un 1 por ciento de la
superficie del sáhara podríamos
alimentar las necesidades energéticas de
la población por lo tanto tenemos
suficiente recurso energético en forma
de radiación solar o en forma de
radiación solar convertida en viento en
calor en mareas en olas
por tanto si tenemos tanta radiación
solar tanta energía renovable porque no
somos capaces de utilizarla tenemos la
tecnología para aprovechar ese recurso
renovable y utilizar nuestro propio
beneficio
y creo que de nuevo la respuesta es sí
durante las crisis del petróleo del
siglo pasado empezaron varios programas
de energías renovables para intentar
capturar la energía de las olas la
energía de las mareas la energía del sol
la energía del viento en el mar en
tierra la energía geotérmica de esos
programas que se desarrollaron en el
siglo 20
ha habido dos tecnologías que han tenido
un éxito relevante y que hoy en día
podemos decir que podemos usar con éxito
me refiero a la energía solar
fotovoltaica y la energía eólica
la energía solar fotovoltáica su
principio lo descubrió lo definió
einstein y desde entonces se ha ido
desarrollando primero en las misiones
espaciales
luego cuando no había posibilidad de
conexión a red y luego poco a poco
conectando grandes sistemas a la red
eléctrica solamente en los diez últimos
años la energía solar fotovoltáica ha
bajado su precio un 80 por ciento pero
eso no es todo la energía solar
fotovoltáica va a seguir bajando el
precio de tal forma que hoy en día en
españa en portugal y en muchos otros
países del mundo la energía solar
fotovoltáica es la fuente de energía
eléctrica más barata que conocemos y
como decía en los próximos diez años
esta tendencia se va a acelerar por lo
tanto tenemos un claro ganador de las
fuentes de energía renovables la energía
solar pero hablaba también de la segunda
fuente la energía eólica
la energía eólica también se irá
desarrollando a lo largo de los años y
ha tenido una reducción de costes no tan
espectacular como la fotovoltaica pero
sí importante de tal forma que hoy en
día en españa en portugal y en otros
países la energía eólica es la segunda
fuente de energía eléctrica más barata
que tenemos pero cuidado cuando el sol
no está arrollando es la fuente de
energía eléctrica más barata que
conocemos y la verdad es que las dos
combinadas energía solar y energía
eólica producen un binomio que nos
proporciona una seguridad de suministro
muy importante si estas dos energías la
combinamos con la energía hidráulica
allá donde hay recursos tenemos un
trinomio de energías renovables con las
cuales podemos jugar por lo tanto creo
que tenemos recursos renovables y
tenemos tecnología para transformar ese
recurso renovable principalmente en
electricidad pero claro si recordáis el
diagrama del principio nuestra economía
se basa en un 80% en recursos fósiles
porque usamos recursos
en nuestro uso diario en nuestros coches
en nuestra movilidad en nuestras casas
podemos cambiar los usos energéticos que
nosotros tenemos a esa electricidad
renovable que se puede producir con los
recursos del sol el agua y el viento
pues yo creo que aquí de nuevo la
respuesta es sí
el coche eléctrico el coche eléctrico ha
pasado de ser una curiosidad tecnológica
a ser una realidad en nuestras
carreteras en españa hemos llegado a 100
mil vehículos eléctricos en febrero en
el mundo 10 millones de vehículos
eléctricos pero esto es solo el
principio hay cuatro factores que van a
hacer que el vehículo eléctrico sea una
realidad nuestras carreteras con el paso
de los años el primero es la autonomía
los vehículos eléctricos de hoy tienen
entre 400 y 500 kilómetros de autonomía
suficiente para el uso que tenemos
segundo es el número de modelos
disponibles si vemos los anuncios de las
marcas de coches podemos ver que casi
todas ellas anuncian ya vehículos
eléctricos puros o vehículos híbridos
enchufables el tercero es la
infraestructura de recarga que ya se
está desplegando en muchísimos países y
que va a permitir a los usuarios de los
coches eléctricos cargar cuando lo
necesiten y el cuarto y casi el más
importante es la competitividad el coste
de tener un vehículo eléctrico
las proyecciones dicen que en el año
2025 tener un coche eléctrico va a ser
más barato que tener un coche de
combustión interna pagar por el coche
más la electricidad que consume va a ser
más barato que pagar por un coche de
combustión interna y el combustible que
consume pero no sólo eso en el año 2027
y 2028 comprar un coche eléctrico va a
ser más barato que comprar un coche de
combustión interna a partir de entonces
el crecimiento del vehículo eléctrico
será exponencial en 2030 tendremos ya
130 millones de vehículos eléctricos en
nuestras carreteras y a partir de
entonces hasta el 2050 casi todo será
eléctrico por lo tanto la movilidad será
eléctrica y usará esas fuentes de
energía renovables la otra parte del
gran consumo energético de nuestras
sociedades es el calor en la unión
europea' el 50 por ciento de la energía
se consume en calentar cosas nuestra
comida nuestra industria nuestras casas
podemos de verdad utilizar electricidad
energía eléctrica renovable en vez de
quemar cosas la respuesta es que si
tenemos ya tecnologías para hacer ello
pero hay una en concreto que va a
permitir un gran uso de la electricidad
para calentar nuestros hogares estoy
hablando de la bomba de calor un
dispositivo que consigue extraer calor
del exterior y meterle en nuestras casas
con una eficiencia de 4 veces la energía
consumida por lo tanto también buenas
noticias desde el punto de vista del
consumo podemos cambiar y debemos
cambiar nuestros usos y quitarnos la
adicción a los combustibles fósiles para
movernos o para calentarlos
así que si os parece
volvemos a nuestro cavernícola del
principio
y quería responder que hoy en el siglo
21 no es necesario como nuestro
cavernícola quemar nada para conseguir
energía podemos obtener energía del agua
del sol y del viento podemos
transformarla en electricidad con la
tecnología que tenemos y podemos usar
esa electricidad renovable para movernos
para calentarnos para generar toda la
industria que es necesaria y en
definitiva para hacer que este mundo
funcione tal y como es pero con un
modelo sostenible hagamos de esta crisis
esta gran oportunidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]